okay now watch wait so you're talking
because you're talking about how canelo
is
pushing him yes back guys yeah yeah and
he's the bigger fighter right right
right but you said on his back foot he'd
be on his back foot i fight on my back
oops right though because i was talking
so he he's on his back foot if he's
watch this
okay now we're both gonna agree you made
a mistake and you did it twice and you
did the same exact device right
back-to-back oops right now we don't
want to do that right right hey we don't
do that to each other no we don't do
that because we're brothers oh yes okay
when you do that what you're saying to
me is i'm not in your family yeah i am
and it's a rerun right yeah this just
happened there's a replay it's a free
everyone watching slow motion so why
would you interrupt me during a replay
when i'm in the middle of the car
because you already saw it right okay so
that's kind of three oopses in a row
and that's all right i'm just watching